Oprah brings out this guest she gives  her this huge intro she's been on this  she's been on that and she does the most  difficult job on the planet she's the  mother  so immediately I look at my girlfriend  I'm like really  being a mom is the most difficult job on  the planet  how many mothers died on Ice Road  Truckers last season any moms mom get  washed overboard on Deadliest Catch  you want to scoop scallops off the  bottom of the ocean or do you want to  hang in the sunshine with a couple of  Rugrats  you can do in your pajamas is not  difficult  it isn't yeah to hell with these mothers  look I'm messing around but you know  come on I know it's a difficult job but  the most difficult job in the whole  planet remember when Saddam let the oil  fields on fire and those poor bastards  had to go put them out  4 000 degrees walking in with your  little asbestos Shield just walking into  flames  you want to do that or watch Bob the  Builder again I mean be honest with  yourself